和美 savvy れるぽいぞ
plante
hey
[拍手]
tan
nanana ああああブー
[音楽]
ブーっ
とんっ
4第8年マーケット1年前はぁ
ブーブーチャー
はで8台の2倍の人数だってれない太っ
今回自分でオフィシャルゲットを分離し
ましたもうカーサー
[拍手]
w
僕らをしたことあるのに良い歯のリードで
読み込めですエドモン一緒にもツボ巣かっ
たです twitter
[拍手]
ブーバーし
ん
ブーブーことはあー
ヌー
練習ターイム
gooyeah
me
して1も在影グラッ意気込みかしゃん意気
込み込みしか具合もでございます
ライブないけどね fc 脅威かもう
ボッコボコにしますキャッチーズー
いやーもう個人的にもロック以外のでも
パワーたとホヤをあマジのバスケプレイね
全力です
東8号にしようと思いますカーチェイス
eudora 分nars 対象が作った
遺書を踏まえしょん
aniするだけでござるでござる衰退して
くれちゃいます自分で麺通堂マンツーます
そんな杯数左腕処理
あっはぁ
が走り買ってもらいますえっ
return
ああああああ
をすればしよう
ana 時に税額入ったほうがよ4日
ブーブー
バーガー
ブーバーありがとうますスペクタクル
プレジで体育の時間と休み時間にしか飛ば
せしてくれないんですけどがんばります
今日はちょっと覚えても怪我しないように
守りながら
はじめ佐藤さんに勝ちたいと思います
宜しくお願いしますあっつの空からすーっ
不安で一杯ですね
ブーブーんですけどユーチューバー
ぬぅあああああああっ
バッハ
さあいよいよ注目の対戦が始まりました
はじめ射場チーム対4 a 棟4対84人
対8人の変則マッチになりますまずは
ジャンプボールラインをしっかり使うの
まま下がっていきましたこのあたりは
さすがですね身長191センチありまー
入ったは弊社で例会ですでもええ
なぜこれもいいですよはいこの大キター
ブーブー1いいよねいい形で入ってきた人
だパラ牧エアーおりましたねちょっとこの
後もある情報をながらだバスけど浅葱でき
ないですかそうですねあのやっぱりたい人
集めるってのもなかなか素敵難しいです
からねえええ
ん人数多いから難しいね a
御秀堂っていきました後はなかなかやはり
パケット経験が乏しいと枠を捉えることが
できないという防衛とチームになります
吠えがキックと区出身の方が多いのでね
こう
運動を吸ってないんじゃないかみたいな
はいイメージがこそあるんですけど結構
みんな活発で遊ぼうですが運動系の動画も
曲出してるらしいね a
例えばのその経験というのがこの試合に9
かどうかこの後注目ですはい人数はいます
8人のとパスの回っていくかどうかしかし
ここ遠目からのシュートんわー
チェーンですかファニボンド一気に
カウンターを仕掛けていきますねードーン
と決めたらもうよっていますねこのあたり
のこのさあ選手の甘さですね
怖いの護衛
存在喝破するんです
意外と牽制が動かない恋やっぱり相手が髪
に入るとですね
いくらバスケットボール経験者でも入り
シュートに行くまでが難しいだとかね
あとは積極的に打っていきますよね煌8は
ない遠藤デヘントこれがつながってさらに
右のサイドから方自分車キラー
俺はとに届けたいチョコであの相方さんの
寝姿が接近ねそういう2気になるところ
だけですけど a 5点差がついたもう
すぐやっぱり動いてるみんなぜええ
アーサーすなわち中ちょっと始めたのね
ゴール慎重とみたいんですけれども早い
早い
最近カウンター一人で行きますただここ
まで校8チームはまだポイントがありませ
ん
やっぱりねますケットって昇進さあのかた
とやってた人ならうそうですね
僕だと思っ今もかなりゴールをしたでは
ありましたけどほんとここでようやくへ
逸れ言いましたございますと実はですね
ほぼ徹夜明けだったんですよあぁそうじゃ
ないガキんちょと言い訳させるだけだけど
ねくれようやくですがこの後体力が持つか
というところも非常に心配ですねそうなん
でそマーケットこれって5人でやる
スポーツなんて女人の時点で仕事量かーっ
麻薬もう意見
さあこのまあこのように海女カフェて大変
なし配布している食事あってはい
ではもし夫不幸
地下客することができませんでしたまた
はじめチームになります
eebe が過ぎても
ブーブー opl あああああっっ[ __ ]
はは去っ
の ui 精一杯
パティ rai
を立ちましたと4 f にとっておかなく
選手は非常に重要なキーマンになってくる
かもしれませんポーズ大紀行ということで
遊びたいし始め中文ハリウッドのスター
選手でスペアは選手が方ね本館
あのーて履帯にちょっと y
空虚でいい感じたいんですよそうですね
そこで8月をもっての手を抜かないという
部分もやっぱり大事かなと思っ地ですね
これでも甘えて言われていましたさすごい
いやー見事ですべくでトウヤ杯
さあこれ12対4覚ますとしひらきました
プリプレスと編みがちゃんとああんっ
[音楽]
可愛いけどもあったここもあっております
ねええ
なかなかゴールを決められないという
ポイントですさあそしてまたあためチーム
4人でござっ日あの聞いてください a &
パンツを受け取ると僕が済むんですかああ
ああを受け取った金でも多くパワー選手も
すごいですけども合格流行る受け取る側と
だしたがは意思疎通ができないんじゃい
ましたよ
ちょっとだけマジん
や祖父がですねはい停滞開いてきました
ねー体力的に始める社長方法
衰えてないということを感じますけどね
まだやはり始まったばかりですからそう
ですねーからこの人数の差がどう響くかが
入りどころかも知れませんそっかーさー
シュートいきますただやはり
赤な角を高いボールを決めることができ
ません意外と貼ってるところ小さいです
からねそうですね練習した人が a
入りやすいですねぇー
なぜサッカーとかってはい一類第二合同
ですね以外笹と infinite とか
もうファンって決めるんですけど
バスケット声ちいないですからねかなりた
から加工まぐれとかうん b nars
ラックが起こりづらいちょいでもはい
まさにその沿いでいるおっお前
ですねえんちゃんですねべびたっピアなん
だっ低い
なかなかゴールに穴をあけることができ
ません
うわぁ
トップ選手ですやはり上手いですねー
さあこれで8店さあこれで発注さですね
ちょっとずつ変えていって繁栄
これがこのパターンがやはりいいですね
綺麗な動きを本でさあ肌まだ梅雨はあり
ますよ3ポイント狙っていうか
b-side
あー下に書いたような初心者シュートで
ございます
そうですねなっちゃうよやなっちゃいます
よねそう悪くないですからさあそして智也
決めていきました
あっイヤーの初心者知れたからのご容赦
なしという感じますね
経験さとの差がまあ気になっちゃうそう
ですね
なかなかの bing にあたることすら
なかなかないというポイントです
[音楽]
さあ
carああああああ
ああああああ
はい出ましたが
ana
[拍手]
4おっはー
あああああそうですねはい
今日はっはあああああで落ち着いています
があの当時もねー度君見たポーズからって
いうあの
ば
あああああはい見てたんですねこれ多分
あの東映との皆さんを気遣ってくれたん
でしょうねあとではこれとリングにも
やはり赤らめそしてきましたさあです oo
ハーパーぴょんっ
本当
声とボーイ変わりますし彼らは変わって
行くうわー
安全がありますね姫ていきました da の
10分数はついていけばそう8
まだ18たい8かなりこの人数がよくやっ
てる方がどうなるんだよ
そんなんは当時のパスがつながらない
落とす月 a
その基に次節戻るもう時間があったもんね
そうなんですよそれでも僕作戦でしてあ
そうですか
あっちが自分の攻める側ところにいると
はいなければそのまま木主なのだわーその
マッハしかしつながりはさんですかなと
思いましたが
smap レスゴールしたはい左サイドが
陰でこれじゃあねんか
まっイヤーを捉えることありませんしかし
もう一度はじめ車窓れ
つながればというところ透明
うわぁ
teramae傾いたあああ
いやー慶応大学の
明日煙出身ですからねすごいよねもうです
よもう待ってのなぜ
まったくを決めるから東へ
ちそうさん今ゲーム実況してるんでしょ
さらにの文化の t バックがあります
ねぇ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーブー
操作しはまり込むておきたい
コードの調子は悪いですけれどもそれは誰
からですが突然声で亡くなったって言って
ますねちょっと怖いいるしなさい何らかの
病気なんじゃないかっていうとが今 a
ここは
ほしい
今おおぉあっ明日から入った選手です
事って言うかでちょっとやったことあるん
だったあれ
シュート精度が一人だね違いますよねです
よ
この後で人数言い思え等しかしこいつ
ほんま欲しいかな花は時計だけで調子です
ね6ですねんあの当時
そもそも一度初めにチームデス作事丁我々
の体力を削れて言ってますからねいや確実
にそうですよねその10分しから例えば
通じないですけど何かぜ4人で行ったり
これだけ動くとで a
いくら経験者だと体力が入る
改めてねほんとしたからなぁ
決めていきました店もらおうと作っていき
ました
人数がいてもお構いなし難波選手ハンター
一人でもできると a
思っていロッカーセットが2人のいっぱい
いうことみたいねそうですねまたね
コンビネーションがね
痛いですけどまんま発生昭和だ
さあハッフルもれ10点サイトついていた
んですがこれならとヤッサここで早めの
終了がホイッスルです
さあ前半戦ご覧になってまどうしてこのぞ
4人のメンバーはちょっとこのね10分
しか戦うと聞いてないんで後半不安は残り
ますまでねー
[音楽]
ああああああmeが8ことぐらい風手助け
美味しかったです
ます
強いってげっサビだワイン煮 by ある
からですよ
rar
エロ星人のうちなんです違って絶対ボール
に近い人が居るからはいと連発8秒だった
絶対てる人が
[音楽]
ブーブーに上げますさあ行為に始まりまし
た改めて応援の男子が2倍のセンスそして
女子に感謝はロンバール田数が付きます鯉
よフェ打ったら8じゃない待ったかいも
あってが入ったら4 ae 多いとという
ことでちょっとサービスとしちゃいました
よですか緒志麻子の奇跡のねー3入ると
12ポイントまいりますよでも生きてえ
ただ我々はもうその活気で言ってますから
体力がねどこまでも続くかちょっと10分
なんでね何度もつながっている見込みで
このルールにしていました
の向こうから4 f です窓は賞縮めて
いきたいと駒大パスがカットされる可能性
があるんでねさあ大これをこれはもう確実
に背景や同社部屋 o
わからない
じゃあこれでまた9点差ですから開きます
登録しましょうてもうただったねそうです
ねーよしよし金取ってんちゃんにも
全部匂いがしてきましたもう一息という
感じかんってー
安い店が多くて大変ですよねぇー
やしかしこれつながりますこれは呼吸が
ありません
かなりね高度な要求がありますよねおっ
はーme
rarラーメンに立って大変でも2ででき
ましたけども知らせ
からん
やはりモールド勤務時間は長いぺー
もう
そうこのシュートはは得られない活動が
とりましたん
散歩へと
ずですねほんとにほんとにこれをね細かく
ねつないでいって
pot 上からの癒してくれ
最大級点数が続きます
強い良い相手のするといい人で結構試合
変わりますかはいん
それをまた再びも取り戻していきたい
ところ
きました
いやー
外れた
初めの3が見たいものってください
私は早いか
得なパスがってなんぞ
あるかあるのかなぁ
さあ3障まああのボールがありますかそれ
まさか
と安い
これ高さは座の前にディフェンスに入っ
てることでこれ教えてコスモ限られます
もんねえが付いてなかなかで寝ないんだよ
ね
と難しいああっ
てるんだああああああチャンジン向かって
ねハッ中間名前はですん
ピザは硬くなりました
それぞれ早い展開で逆転に向けねー
シュート初
本当に美味しい
補正さんっ
取ったの始めんチームそして逆サイドには
沢がいます
これですよはいじゃあとポイントからルパ
遺言とラッシュとは決めていきました我々
マって言ってるんですよ普通に発展のが
あるんで
ここにいかに訂正稼ぐかだそうですねー
どうぞ応援ってを決めただけでペアー
いやーやってる入るところでしたねー
逆転違って釣れましたねそうですねー
さあこのシートああ
決められませんねぇちょっとゴールに嫌わ
れたことですけどゴール生きられる時間
んだ
まずははしちょっと覚えた
アーサー奪っ本当にいやーほんとにね
惜しいシーンがねぇちょっと行ってきまし
たからねぇ
6号もう一的でなくつかめそうですよねえ
感覚がちょっと聡さんもアップレモール
張ってリズムを取るタイミングが遅くなっ
てますのでちょうど集中しやすいてバーッ
と馬のは ua と遊びネットございませ
んが発送
このディフェン覚えようこれとにこれを
自由に打たせてしまうと
いけない羽目ここ思います見ても何も来て
いくんだよここ
コミックだ秋冬
この距離振ってしまいを元に戻るのがね
結構なくですよねそうですよね入って
しまえばいいんですけどね簡単なかも
いけるよ
あおちゃん言葉たじゃあ
[拍手]
こうさんかっこいいけど彼はいえそうです
ねこんな可愛い断層の貴公子 is 6
ですよねぇー
ねこちは3m と口出たぞ
ハイリターン
札幌店さんよしをシェアします今もほんと
一瞬で詰められる点数になってきてます
そうですね井端の姑は舅は
うわぁ
だこれんスター入ってはもう後はですよ
ああそうも無いですし体力もねはい力お
願いですかねぇ
ani生まれん
紅米加工一生河合町
よイェーイああああああ
成功します ah上尾出すとでございまし
たねやーさっぱりパスタ連摂津にこれは
これもいいいい
あああああシュートが開けるとそうの
ルール的な欠陥が感じできましたけどです
ねちょっとでもう取り返しはつかん性をな
仕方ない a 4みましょう
聞いていますのでー
ええええええ
ミューザを
ですね速攻なぁかなり金山ともやんいい
バッター
djane
サイドからボールをつないでいきます散布
のマチックラー麺系からいいファイター
アーテックはこれぞ
差別に守る前
さあ交わしながらパス
国をはじめのチームの字簡体字ですいい
具合聞こえませんでしたもそれ廃絶体力的
な部分もきつくなってきている気がします
佐俣48チームのボールよるなかな
終わった美味しいですこれで7点差40対
さあこれもうどんどんとターン差が開き
ますのでああここでシュール2両が切れて
いたりそうですねぇー
2時の的にあってくるあのもどこ汗クラス
を貼っとい怖いですねー
態度こそねっなければいいですな
音はテクをぜええっ
んでした
さあまたここディフェンスが辛い
これやばいよはい
goo
いやああああああいいいい撮影はいけない
不調
日本のシュート5分室ナビてこれはっはー
行為に
フィジカルだけで決めていった
wh
ブーブー言っ
ロスター味方動かて仕えさせるの大事です
本当にそうですねー
力とスター
[音楽]
ちょっと様やこれを全員のもう時続けない
といけないですかねこれチームはねもう
結構ホットねえよこれでチームはちょっと
多少したとってもね大丈夫ですか
ああああああ
いやー決められないなと一体こういった
チームディフェンス桜
数がほらもう
日ベースで結構戻りをして待ってますから
それぞれ a
niの cl とん
といけぽんたろうさんと後ろパーの
ルーターこれ
3本8現金フリーの春季です発砲し夏休み
ます
そこはとまこ
ちょっと体力的な僕も版が1回やるとか
やりましたもう限界ちょっと誰か入っ
ちゃうかも知れませんからねーじゃんっ
持っていたいるかもじゃない
さあ体力がやばいという話もありました
着実に年を重ねている肇社長です pen
3巻で待ったらねこれそうですね
よくぞ黒マネー伸ばせるかと
おったのだぞいま水面を救っ育つくーん
まあ今よしたしパスです
me議論をとって地方からさ
1つを得るときはなければいけないああ
ああああああ
takanon 見せました8てんだねっ
ただちょっとともや誕生日会でいて欲しい
なってねーねーそうですねそれはノー
コメントです入ったまだの時間ありますよ
ええ
後ろからあーそりゃもう
tan
ライトボックスにポイントは3点ええっ
デカいんで例えば大きいビってくる相手の
流行ったを勝利だね
うーん
[拍手]
そしたら1話
dj これ
をイウジャパントレーディングがありまし
たらです
この復興的
いやーホッとしたからキャプチャー立って
います
you were
また方へとチームの棒に加えます
女の子2人でドナー明日か本当にして多
そう分かったでしょんme
ムズってとってサッカー
とくよスーツ
そうからボールは勝手だば3ポイントだ
ああああああああもう時間がそっと a子
ってなってましてこれやばいこれ入った方
を終わりますよねそんな入ったらもうええ
第二波
だけどああああっここで終了のホイッスル
ですいいっ
そうですね薬
w 強いよ市立倫の体力がう任務耐える
理由とキッズのは鬼門だいわれますはい
ポイントと農薬と4フラワーやかーいつも
ありポンド札れないはいありがとうござい
ます
の mc を入れてまいりましょうはい
あっ
[音楽]
はーる
el